[تصفيق]
ايران دعوه لاضراب وسعي وما غد الخميس
والمدن ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه تعاني بين
انقطاع الانترنت
مع تسعيط طهران نوويه الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل تبحثان اجرام و مناورات تحاك
الهجوم على ايران
تويتر تخبر قاضيا اتحاديا بان الدعوه
التهامها بانتهاك القانون بتصريحها الالاف
من الموظفين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الاهم الانباب من العربيه البدايه من
ايران حيث وضعت مجموعه تطلق على نفسها
الشباب ثوار في ايران الى اغلاق المحلات
والاعمال
البلاد وذلك تضامنا مع المدن الكرديه
في ايران المنظمات
الشعب الايراني بتنظيم اضراب العام يوم
الخميس من اجل تعزيز الوحده والتضامن ودعم
الشعب الكردستاني
بشكل الموازنه فائده قناته ايران
انترناشونال بانه تم قطعه خدمه الانترنت
في المدن ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه في البلاد
مباشره
الماضي من قبل السلطه
[موسيقى]
سيراميك
في ايران تعددت وسائل النظام الايراني
القوات الامن بالعنف والتحرش بالمنتظاهرين
والمتظاهرات في مراكز الاحتجاج وتؤكد
التقارير معلومات
حقيقيه على لسان ضحايا عمليات اغتصاب كان
اخرها انتهاكات جسديه ونفسيه بحق صبي
مراهق تقرير المحطه الامريكيه نقل عن
مصادر مطلعه ان قوات الامن صورت مشاهد
العنف الجسدي وحولتها الى اداه الابتزاز
المتظاهرين واسكتهام
[موسيقى]
هو في محاوله اللي صار فيها
اخرجت ايران ورقه الملف النووي اذا كانت
الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه النيران
تخصب اليورانيوم
بدات في انتاج اليورانيوم المخصب باستخدام
من اجهزه طرد المركزي
الموجوده في محطه لتخصيب الوقود حجيره الى
ان تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 60% يجري ايضا
ابريل من العام الماضي
النسبه هي نسبه قريبه من الدرجه اللازمه
لصنع يصلح
بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا ردت بخططه ايران
لتوسيع برنامجا النووي بعد تاكيد الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه توسع ايران في
تخصيب اليورانيوم في فوردونالدز مؤكده
الدول الثلاث انها ستواصل التشاور مع
شركاء الدوليين بشان افضل السبل للتعامل
مع تصعيد النووي الايراني المستمره
من جهته اعرب البيت الابيض عن قلق واشنطن
العقيق بشان التقدم الذي تحرزه ايران في
برنامجها النووي وتطوير قدراته الصاروخيه
البالستيه المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
لن تسمح لايران بامتلاك القدره لحيازه
السياحي
لحظه الولايات المتحده واسرائيل اجراء
مناورات العسكريه مشتركه تحاكم هجوم على
ايران ووكلائها في المنطقه بحسب ما فادت
وقناه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه
للقناه فان رئيسي الاركان الاسرائيلي
والامريكي ماركلي
اجرام مناورات المشتركه للقوات الجويه
خلال الاسابيع القادمه
وسيتم خلالها تدريب العسكريين على العمل
بين اسرائيل
ايضا في هذه النشره قالت شركه تويتر لقاضي
الانتخابيه في سان فرانسيسكو ان الدعوه
التي تدعمون الشركه القانون الامريكي
قبل ذلك قال ماسك مالك منصه تويتر ان شركه
التواصل الاجتماعيه قررت تاجيل اطلاقه
خدمات الاشتراك بالعلامات الزرقاء وهو
تاخير عن الجدول زمني المبدئي لاعاده
الخدمه على المنصه
على تويتر سبب تاجيل اعاده اطلاق علامات
التحقق الزرقاء الى ضروره التحقق والحصول
على ثقه عاليه في حال انت حال الهوى
بعد ان ترد ماسك كبار المديرين التنفيذيين
وخفض اعداد الموظفين دون سابق انذار
اثريستيلائه على منصه تويتر تحت شعار اذا
كنت لا تحب ماسك تعال واعمل معنا شركات
التقنيه تستقطب موظفه تويتر الذين غادروا
الموقع رساله الى كل من ترك تويتر نشرتها
احدى الشركات تطالبهم بالالتحاق بها ورغم
ان شركه التكنولوجيا الامريكيه الكبرى
الاخرى بما في ذلك ميتا وامازون قامت
بتسريح الاف الموظفين في الاسابيع الاخيره
بسبب البيئه الاقتصاديه لكن الانتقاد
العلنيه
على العمال الرقمين ذوي المهارات العاليه
الذين شغلوا مناصب حساسه في تويتر ولعل
شركات التكنولوجيا الامريكيه المنافسه
تسعى للاستفاده من خبرتها هؤلاء الموظفين
والمهندسين خاصه بعد نجاحات السنوات
الماضيه التي حققها طائره تويتر برفقتهم
وفي غضون ذلك تخبطات المنصه مستمره في ظل
قرارات المالك الجديده ايلون ماسك الذي
جعل العالم كله يهتم باخبر تويتر اكثر من
اي شيء اخر بلال العربيه
وفي بريطانيا
خشيه كبيره يشعر بها مستخدم تويتر في
بريطانيا بعد الاضطرابات التي شهدتها
المنصه الاجتماعيه اثر استحواذ ال الماسك
عليها فما لبس ان استلم مسك شؤون الشركه
حتى بدا بتغيرات جذريه لاسباب الاقتصاديه
واخرى سياسيه وصفها البعض بانها اتخذت
بسرعه مبالغ فيها في ما وصف خبراء ماسك
بانه لا يعرف ماذا يقوم به وقد برزت الى
الواجهه منصه مثل هايف وغيرها كخيار من
دون ان تثبت كفاءتها حتى الساعه في الحلول
محلات تويتر
واستبدالها يجب ان يحصل ذلك بشكل تلقائي
اذ لن يقرر العالم كله مره واحده الانتقال
الى منصه جديده ولهذا السبب اعتقد انه من
الصعب استبداله بسهوله اعتقد فعليا ان
تويتر هو الخيار الوحيد الذي لدينا
والى جانب التغريدات المثيره للجدل التي
ينشرها ماسك بين الحين والاخر وتسريح
عشرات الموظفين من مكاتب الشركه حول
العالم او موجه الاغلاقات التي طالت
مكاتبهم بشكل مؤقت او دائم احيانا وفرض
رسوم على مستخدمي الاشاره الزرقاء وقراري
ماسك باعاده شخصيات المثيره للجدل مثل
ترامب وكانيوست كل هذه الاسباب ربما تكون
دفعت العديده الى البحث عن منصه تواصل
بديله او الى تقليص الوقت الذي يقدمه على
منصه امم اوروبا
مثل التعليقات المعاديه للساميه او
العنصريه التي سيتاح للناس الان التحدث
بها
رئيس تويتر على ماسك الاهتمام بموظفيه هو
لا يقوم بذلك الان بعد تسريح العديد كما
ان اتاحه الفرصه لدونالد ترامب للعوده الى
المنصه لها بعد خطير بسبب الاخبار الزائفه
مستخدمين تويتر حول العالم وقد لجا بعض
موظفين منصه الى نقاباتهم المحليه بحث عن
حمايه من اساليب ماسك في معامله الموظفين
مكاتب تويتر في لندن في هذه البنايه هنا
شهدت اغلاقات مؤقته هي الاخرى بعد استلام
ماسك للشركه وهو الذي اتخذ عده اجراءات
زادت من التكهنات بان منصه تويتر بعثت في
خطر اما من الناحيه الاقتصاديه او من
ناحيه الوظيفه الاخلاقيه والمهنيه من
المنظر العروب عبد الحق العربيه
تتابعونا ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
واشنطن تستعد لتقديم اربعه مليارات و500
مليون دولار لاوكرانيا من خلال البنك
الدولي
اهلا بكم من جديد
انها ستقدم مساعده ماليه بقيمه اربعه
مليارات و500 مليون دولار الى اوكرانيا
بهدف تعزيز الاستقرار الاقتصاديه والدعم
الخدمات الحكوميه الاساسيه
واضافتنا المساعدات سوف تساعد اوكرانيا في
مواجهه الحرب التي تشلها روسيا من خلال
تعزيز الاستقرار الاقتصادي ودعم الخدمات
الحكوميه الاساسيه بما في ذلك اجور
العاملين في المستشفيات والموظفين
الحكوميين والمعلمين وقال رئيس البنك
الدولي
منفصل ان البنك جمع حتى الان نحو 17
مليارا
و800 مليون دولار بشكل تمويل طارئ لدعم
الشعب الاوكراني وصرف اكثر من احد عشر
مليارا و400 مليون دولار من هذا التمويل
حتى
ميدانيه تعرضت تشبه جزيره القرم الخاضعه
لسيطره الروسيه في اوكرانيا لهجوم بمصيرات
فيما كانت القوات الروسيه في حاله التاهب
وفق ما اعلنت السلطات المعنيه في موسكو
وقال حاكم منطقه سيفوستوفل الاداريه في
شبه جزيره القربه على تلغرام ان المنطقه
تتعرضت لهجوم للمسيرات ووضحنا مسيرتين
اسقطت حتى الان مؤكدا عدم تضرري اي بنيه
تحتيه مدنيه
انقطاع الكهرباء
الى حين الاستقرار الوضع خاصه بعد انخفاض
درجات الحراره الى ما دون الصفر درجه
المدينه الجنوبيه حاضره ولايه انتاج
البطيخ الذي اصبح بعد ذلك رمزا لتحريرها
سيطر الروس على هذه المدينه في ذات تاريخ
الاجتياح الكامل للاراضي الاوكرانيه وظل
يسيطرون عليها
الاوكرانيون عن التخلي عنها بعد انقادوا
هجوما مضاده بدات اثاره واضحه على الطريقه
وقطعوا خطوط الامداد خلف الروس فنسحبوا
منها
خاصه القرى والبلدات والمناطق السكنيه
القريبه من ناردين برو لان الاعداء
موجودون مباشره عند الضفه الاخرى ويقومون
باطلاق النار على مواقعنا بالصواريخ
والمدفعيه وبكل انواع الاسلحه
معظم الاحياء تعاني من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي وامدادات المياه والغاز التدفئه
بل ونقص في الغذاء يهدد السكان
يجيد كهرباء
لكننا سنعيش في هذه الظروف افضل من ان
نعيش في وجود الروس نحن شعب حر ونحب بلدنا
اوكرانيا المجد الاوكرانيا والمجد للابطال
في المدينه
دتدفئه ولا مياه ولا كهرباء ولا شبكه
اتصالات ولا انترنت الوضع صعب لكننا
مؤمنون بان كل ذلك سيعود قريبا
فصل الشتاء بدات في تفسير القوافل
الانسانيه وفتحت بابا النزوحي على نفقه
الدوله ترحيلا واسكالا واطعامها
لقد اتينا واحضرنا المساعدات الانسانيه
وايضا المتخصصين من ولاياتنا الذين سيبقون
هنا لمساعده المدينه في اعاده امدادات
الطاقه والمياه وكل ما يحتاجه الناس للعيش
بشكل طبيعي
في حضور قوته المسلحه التي ما انفرغت من
السيطره على المدينه حتى باشرت عمليه
اما المدنيون فيقولون انهم باقون في
موطنهم رغما عن الظروف لقناتي العربيه
والحدث وليس عادل خرسون
صواريخو برستون البريطانيه وصلت الى
اوكرانيا لجعل حياه الجنود الروس جحيما
بحسب صحيفه التلغرام سلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني ارسل صواريخ وهي احدث نسخه من
الصواريخ الموجهه بالليزر ويمكنها الوصول
الى المسافه بعيده كما يمكن استخدام هذه
الصواريخ في المناطق السكنيه كبيره مما
يحد من احتماليه حدوث اضرار الجانبيه بين
المدني
[موسيقى]
قال يشعرون حكوميه بمدينه 23
الف الف مبروك للمنتخب السعودي الى العراق
الاغلبيه الكرديه تعاني من انقطاع
الانترنت
مع تسعيدي طهران نوويه لامريكا واسرائيل
تبحثين اجراءات مناورات تحاك الهجوم على
ايران
البشره الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]